why couldn't we get enough masks why
couldn't we get enough fin lighters why
weren't there the perception that there
weren't enough hospital beds how come
the morgues couldn't keep up and so on
and so on how come we couldn't be
prepared for this and no matter how you
look at it at every area it was a
failure of government Dave Rubin and
this is the Reuben report reminder
everybody lockdown is more fun with
friends and add free video and podcasts
so please consider joining us at Reuben
report.com
and joining me today is the editorial
director at the American Institute for
Economic Research Jeffrey Tucker welcome
back to the Reuben report it's good to
be here Dave nice to see you again good
to see you again I'm sorry we're not
doing this in person but we are social
distancing like everybody else so I
guess my first question to you is well
just how you doing how you doing in a
time of social distancing and lockdown
well I'm gonna give the same answer
anybody would which is I can't believe
that this is the world we live in I
never would imagine there's been three
weeks ago but somehow we're faring we're
not starving we're not dying we're
talking to people and you know I wrote a
book called the market loves you and all
I can say is the market although
bludgeoned and truncated and and it's
never been attacked like this before
maybe in the history of the world it's
still somehow working so I'm very very
grateful for that yeah that seems like
the right start to this because
throughout the last month or so you're
one of the few people I would say that
it's making some consistent sense to me
at least on Twitter and and I think
you're you're a pretty great classical
liberal thinker which is why I wanted to
have your because I want to talk about
stimulus and I want to talk about
markets and I want to talk about the
Constitution and free speech and right
to assembly and all of those things that
that I know you and I and my audience
all love so why don't why don't we start
with
this which is just going off what you
just said there we seem to be more
resilient perhaps than then we thought I
mean I think if you had said to people
six months ago hey do you know that in
March and April you're gonna be shut
down locked in your house along with
virtually the rest of the world for now
going on five weeks and it could be
months after that I think people would
have thought oh there's gonna be
violence oh there's gonna be looting
there's gonna be crime all of these
things and yet as you started us with
we're doing okay and the markets
actually haven't completely tanked we're
going up and down but everything is kind
of working Oh Dave I could tell you such
inspiring stories I just want to cry
when I think about it you know when I go
to the grocery store which is you know
one of the things you can do now it's a
access to real life and I go in there
and I first of all make sure to thank
every single worker there for all of
their that they're doing but I'd like to
talk to the managers about how they
decide what they're going to do that day
you know was there a run on chicken
yesterday what did you do about that
you know was there a run on sausage what
did you do about the salads you know
over here in the deli section how you
getting toilet paper how you ration it
given that there's restrictions on
private price movements how does this
change your lives you know and all I
hear is stories of heroism and
brilliance and and it's not just
individual brilliance its institutional
brilliance and civilians to the market
economy it's still working to spite
everything despite being clobbered in
ways that were unimaginable just a few
months ago and if I can say so David
this brings to mind a real paradox
that's the times we're living through
right now this shutdown has presumed the
adaptability of society you know the
capacity of society to make this radical
turn to go from one life to the other
life practically overnight to adopt it
assuming the impossible pose and and yet
the government edicts that have come
down have presumed the impossibility of
society to adapt to the presence of
pandemic disease you know like we can
adapt is that is that adaptability do
you think that adaptability is unique to
capitalism because of the way it allows
so many people to be in the market and
and innovate and and move as things need
to be moved yeah it's it's it's it's an
embedded in the essence of a free
society where we're where people learn
to be intelligent and learn to control
their world and to partner with people
and create these market signals that
that tell us that prices and interest in
all these things I think you know at the
end of this if you're not a libertarian
you're not paying attention because the
market is were and brilliantly and it's
only not worked when it's been when it's
been hobbled and it has been hobbled you
know it was hobbled before this crisis
actually and we can talk about all the
specific ways in which that's true I
blame I don't get I don't blame
coronavirus for your suffering right now
my virus has always been with us and
always will be and and Society had
developed ways to deal with viruses
medical professionals especially have
learned how to deal with viruses and
it's a challenge for any society under
any conditions the way you want above
all else is freedom and adaptability and
to decentralize decision-making in the
u.s. Dave for some reason we took a
completely different direction
fortunately we haven't shut down the
stock market we have shut down essential
stores and it's thanks to that that
we're eating today you know that we're
sleeping today that we're able to get by
so is but we owe the fact that we're
surviving through this it's it's a
hundred percent the element of freedom
that remains in the system but Jeffrey I
keep reading all these brilliant think
pieces saying how this is the shows the
failure of libertarianism and unlimited
government because this if ever this is
the moment we need
government to do things and the very
people who have been calling Trump
Hitler for four years are now demanding
that he do more with his power is am I
not understanding things properly what
am I missing here I think you and I
share the same frustration the response
of the left has been alarming to me it's
an extent that I find indescribable
because I think last time I was on your
show
I myself was warning about the danger of
the authoritarianism of Trump and and we
can get out of that I think he's made
some bad decisions here and they stem
from his let's explore all of it for
sure yeah and he they extend from his
own nationalism and his own liberalism
really which I think it's gonna
seriously problematic but my god day
after day to see these howling press
people you know like all I have decided
that the narrative is that Trump is some
sort of basquiat figure you know who's
just not doing anything and that people
are dying because of him you know it's a
it's a real shock and III don't want to
say I'm grateful for him because I think
he's Minna's Ayers but the day to day
I'm sure you feel the same way my god if
the Trump administration went along with
what CNN MSNBC it and the I'm sorry to
say unspeakable New York Times New York
Times a venue that I've always adored
and always yeah and I loved and to see
what they did with what they helped
enable I just don't know i if there's
any such thing as moral culpability I
think I'm so sorry to say it again it
breaks my heart I think the New York
Times is morally culpable for what's
happened to this country today and I you
know I I listen to the daily podcast and
I saw the hysteria being ramped up and
they and the demands for crackdowns and
they the call for a medieval response to
this and the demands for I don't know
what you would call it but fascist
communist you know social distancing
policies and it's been grim and shocking
and I you've been shocked I've been
shocked I don't know what to say so it's
so interesting that you're as concerned
about the media element as I am because
it seems to me that we're fighting two
viruses right now we we all know about
the corona virus and how to fight that
but the the misinformation virus that is
now permeating throughout the media and
it's New York Times and it's Vox and
it's CNN and the list goes on and on is
making it almost impossible for any of
us to have what I would say is the same
conversation because we're all dealing
with different sets of information how
concerned generally are you about that
tremendously I actually I summarized
this you have we've all been talking to
friends and what I've been but I press
it the other day that this I plea blame
some your hucksters scientists fake
science I'm paid about bullying media
anti-trump media you know combined with
a panicked political class and it was a
kind of a perfect storm the three
elements came together and led to a
level of wreckage that's that's
unspeakable and I'm moral what nice hey
I have to tell you because you know for
years people have told me about the evil
of the the mainstream media and I've
never really wanted to go there you know
like I'm a big believer in press freedom
and I never wanted to be one of those
people to trash the New York Times you
know and I've and actually I love the
New York Times I always have but I feel
like I've gotten a real wake-up call
here a real shock I don't know how you
can be in the mainstream press today and
and be salivating over the clicks and
the views and and and you know the
amount of ad bias that you're generating
from this while watching freedom just go
down the drain it's it's it's it's been
a shock me I just can't I can't even
describe to you how horrifying has been
to me and I to tell you the truth I've
really turned it off I've had to yeah I
think well we know that people are
turning it off in in tremendous numbers
and watching things like this instead so
as a as a liberty minded person as you
said if people don't come out of this
more libertarian something will have
gone wrong what what are the the proper
approaches for a liberty minded
government so say a liberal libertarian
or classical liberal set of ideas that
could get us through something like this
what should we have done sort of at the
beginning what should we have done as
we're going through it right now and
what should we be looking at for the
future if you want to keep people as
free as possible while also dealing with
something that we've never dealt with
before David our gonna summarize my
position and a sentence it would be
something like this the medical
professionals in the medical industry
free of all restraints should have been
allowed to deal with this virus from the
very beginning without the intervention
of politicians period I mean that that
so basically just yes get rid of red
tape just let them do their thing no
more no more regulations on experimental
treatments that kind of stuff yeah and
not only that but you know if you think
about it Dave a lot of this flattened
the curve analysis that led to the
crackdowns and they've mandatory social
distancing and and the universal house
imprisonment that we're dealing with
right now was due to the perception that
the medical industry was unscalable
in the event of emergency now that's
very interesting you people need to be
asked question if it's true why was an
industry unable to scale industries
specialize in scaling you know when when
people buy more of your product as an
industry you're excited to offer more of
that product or service to them what
makes the medical industry unique in
that respect why couldn't we get enough
masks why couldn't we get enough
ventilators why weren't there the
perception that there weren't enough
hospital beds how come the morgues
couldn't keep up and so on and so on how
come we couldn't be prepared for this
and no matter
you look at it at every area it was a
failure of government it was the system
was was was heavily regulated the
Strategic Medical Reserve
disincentivized hospitals from it from
gathering their own supplies the tariffs
on masks is seriously inhibited and this
is very personal to me because I I have
friends in New York who are nurses and
doctors who were sharing masks I can't
get enough and the tariffs seriously
injured that and the hospitals didn't
have enough supplies on hand because
they assumed that it was all there the
federal government was created all
together but then of course they open
the warehouse and the hash validators
don't work you know the the supplies
aren't there because they had previously
been been depleted every area all you
see is government irrationality the
inability of hospitals to scale the
panic of the political class to force
everybody into their homes which is
definitely where you should not be
whether you have respiratory disease the
poor the answer is to get outside as
everybody understands you don't want to
put old people with young people because
that causes endless amounts of
infections you actually want to isolate
and separate the people who are
vulnerable to this disease which are the
old and and fail and and the last thing
you want to do is close the schools
because kovat as we know now is is it
was actually not fatal for a young
healthy people so at every single area
days the government has done the wrong
thing and I don't know how long or how
detailed we want to get here but the
testing Fiasco was the great I would say
beginning of all this stuff because
China had already gone through a trial
run of this stuff you know we had this
benefit of this we saw this coming and
the CDC and the FDA stopped and this is
a matter of record I really stopped
private researchers from developing the
tests and distributing the tests from
the very beginning of this crisis that
was a catastrophic thing and that led to
what I've called heard me an epistemic
crisis we didn't know we didn't know who
had it
I had it whether you had it what we
should do about it have was transmitted
who is vulnerable to the fatalities what
the case fatality rate is we didn't know
anything so we replaced knowledge that
we could have used with power and panic
and so is one of the inherent problems
that we have
fighting the the bad ideas that would
encroach on our rights that even if you
lay out to people well here's all the
things that government has done wrong
although all the way and here's why it
can never work properly that they always
say well that just means we meet we need
more government that just means we need
to give it more money so it can be
bigger so that we can put more studies
out there to make sure it knows how to
do these things and that answer always
sort of sounds easy and right for people
that aren't really thinking it's much
harder to say to people oh the
government actually should have been
scaled way back on this so we could have
let the professionals deal with it that
that sort of sounds scary to people
especially at a time right now where we
feel like the future is just up in the
air right now yeah I and I think this
speaks to a little bit of something a
principle that's animated your career in
your life which you had a passion some
years ago a realization that people
don't appreciate freedom they don't have
confidence in freedom that freedom was
being attacked fundamentally and
philosophically by both the left and and
and on the right - and I think you
worried about that you actually asked
yourself a very important question what
happens in the event of a crisis where
we need freedom more than ever and yet
we don't have the intellectual
foundations in place where there's not a
cultural love of this thing we call
freedom or an under much less an
understanding of it what happens then
and I think that was a very interesting
perception that you had you know several
years ago that you really dedicated
yourself really hard to this to this
problem
and and and tried your best to do
something about it but I think what
we're seeing right now are the results
of a culture that it's that's that's
forgotten the meaning of freedom that
that and one if you lose that what do
you replace it with it's you replace it
with the police state with yes they're
not good yeah so right now as we as we
sit here all sort of trapped in our
houses trying to figure out what to do
how concerned are you about some of
those basic freedoms that we're talking
about I mean right now the right to
assembly for example we cannot assemble
together you know you can't get ten
people in a room to do anything we had
our our bizarre mayor being nice de
Blasio in New York City say that if he
found temples or churches that were
having any gatherings they could be
permanently closed now again I'm all for
the the six-foot social distancing if
that's what the professionals are
telling us but the idea that we could
permanently close these things and we
can't assemble or our right to free
speech in that we know that even right
now big tech is removing blog posts that
run counter knowledge that's not
necessarily the government stepping in
and doing it but just if we look at just
some of our key freedoms assembly in
speech being the two at the moment how
concerned are you that we're just gonna
sort of put them aside throughout this
and then it'll be six months later and
we'll go oh we had those things yeah I
think anything is possible right now
Dave and anybody who says otherwise
hasn't been paying attention over the
last couple weeks there's no chance it's
how I looked before there before we met
up just now I looked back at what I
wrote January 27th because I I I wrote
an article warning that the quarantine
power could be used and and and
explained why this is a very very bad
idea but even in that article I imagined
something like this that that the
government would set up like quarantine
areas which in fact they have done and
they would come knocking on your door
and grab people out of it maybe one
family at a time and put them in there
in the quarantine area or
you know that they would target maybe
neighborhoods and around everybody up
and put him paddy wagons put him in the
quarantine area but even January 27th I
never imagined the governments of the
world would put everybody under what
amounts to house arrest so the fact that
that this has happened I would say at
this point anything's anything's
possible
I worried because we put out a book last
week called coronavirus and economic
crisis book put out by American
Institute for Economic Research and put
it on Amazon not gonna tell you I was
worried I was worried that Amazon would
take it down so I printed separately
some lots of copies independently with
an independent publisher and started
making it available on the website just
in case we we face massive censorship
I actually if I were going to describe
it I would say we're like that close
that close and once you get rid of and
it's very interesting to me that you use
this word right you've been using this
repeated our right to assemble no right
to assert our right to speak right is
not something that's contingent it's
something that you actually possess it's
not granted to you by the government
something you own by virtue of each
Manatee it's hard to talk about rights
in these times and we don't apparently
have the right to our own property
because the government can shut down our
business on grounds that it's unofficial
right
we probably don't have the right even to
leave our homes that so once you take
that away I mean Dave I don't want to be
alarmist about this or anything but look
from a Asafa core into a point of view
we are living the practical reality of
what comes very close to being a
totalitarian state right now now
fortunately thank you political leaders
you're letting the grocery stores work
fortunately the private you know thank
you for letting us have pharmacies
they're private entities too so we're
grateful for a little bit of private
private private private markets that are
left but but the attack on everybody
else in it and the attack on our rights
is shocking and it's the social
consequences of this are unspeakable
really I mean people are not going to
comply they're not complying now I'm
sure you know this in fact you've
probably attended them but there are
speakeasies and all over in New York
City popping up where you can go to
dinner and gather on more than five more
than ten even 30 people you know and and
they're drinking they're having dinner
together they're there in defiance of
the law friends of mine in Manhattan sit
in their penthouses and and every night
at after nightfall people rush out into
the streets with noisemakers just to
just to illustrate that they believe in
freedom you know and for God's sake are
we not do we not believe in freedom
anymore
I did the politicians presumed that
we're we're like pieces on a chessboard
they can just move around but you know
what it's not true that is not the human
mind we are not inanimate objects we're
not birds in cages
we will live free one way I hope but so
what would you say so of course I'm with
you but what would you say to the people
that would say but all of those people
your friends that are going out onto the
streets at night and the people that are
getting together at speakeasies and
going out more than they have to go out
and the rest of it and exercising their
rights and freedom that those are the
people who are gonna keep this thing
spreading because people don't know what
when to rein in their own personal
responsibility and and do something so
that you know society doesn't crumble
something like that you know at the
height in the Enlightenment you know
where we discovered this idea of human
freedom there was also disease we didn't
have very clean water there you know
there were annual viruses that came
along and killed people and and there
were pandemics and so on but they still
somehow came to believe that human
beings have the right to speak and
associate and trade and we work around
it and and and
the belief and freedom is the confidence
that society has the intelligence to
deal with things like viruses that come
along and the existence of disease does
not disable
the whole of modernity it just doesn't
we can't think this by modernity was for
time and there were diseases and even
back to the Black Death then in Venice
and in the 13th century when it was
there were still interest they still
kept trade going there was there was
there was some towns would come up with
the restrictions and that sort of thing
but but the idea of violating people's
rights fundamental rights to live and
choose and speak and everything was even
then thinkable 500 years ago I mean the
are respond here is is pre-modern
its medieval its its its eleventh and
twelfth century style stuff except with
21st century technology and we're not
responding to the things as
scientifically even you know even the
slightest bit
their response by the political class
and I mean from about March 15th
onward was nothing short of mystical
superstitious I was a panicked response
let's just let's just throw everybody in
a cage of their own creation and and
punishing anybody for coming out of it
and I I just I totally forgive people
who are going to these pqd needs me you
could say that
prudent you know they shouldn't be doing
that but for God's sake people
exercising their fundamental rights I'd
say we need more of that not less of
that right now do you think that's
that's partly just human nature that so
many people just operate purely in fear
so you know like a month ago when we had
that two-day window where suddenly
everything shut down out of nowhere you
know they announced the entire NBA
season was canceled and then they
canceled all these public events and and
everything sort of happened at within a
two-day thing that there becomes this
odd rush to cancel because you don't
want to be the one guy who's going
against the crowd right you don't want
to be the one guy who says no we're not
gonna cancel our season we're not gonna
cancel all of our things we're going to
it out a little bit knowing that the
risk that you take of being just
destroyed by the media and everything
else on the other side is probably worse
than just going along with with with the
crowd with the wave yeah I I understand
your point I have my doubts that there
was any public support for this actually
at all
now it's entirely up to private venues
whether or not they want to you know
have these gatherings or accept the
liability associated with NBA games or
South by Southwest you know and that
sort of thing
South away is Southwest didn't choose a
set to cancel that conference that was a
governmental decision so I'm looking at
this and I'm not saying whether that was
maybe South by Southwest should have
canceled you know I don't know I think
about this a lot I'm not actually sure
about that because that's mostly all
young people there who aren't actually
not in any great danger from covered so
I'm not I'm not sure about that and it's
hard to do counterfactuals here but with
this much Dave I know and I think you
know two politicians by which I mean
governors mayors senators and
congressmen and so on I'm not owners of
anything their main job is to get
blocked it again that's it so they don't
really have a financial economic stake
they don't have skin in the game apart
from the desire to get voters to vote
for them again and there was a sudden
panic on the part of political leaders
that o-levels really that if anybody
died while they were in office that they
would somehow be blamed for this unless
unless they just bludgeoned people you
know and ruin people's lives so they
somehow believed there's less risk to
steal people's property and arrest
people in their homes than it was to to
to be blamed for public death and and
that that gets us back to a problem with
began this discussion the role of the
media here because what they're really
fearing ultimately is is is this cancel
culture you know the the Twitter mobs
and and in the New York Times editorial
page and and and and the media culture
that's this last love lost all
rationality and clearly clarity there
they're afraid of being denounced and
dragged through the mud and and drawn
and quartered and so on by the press
so I ultimately I feel like a perfect
storm to you doesn't that feel and of
just the end of the media that we've all
been seeing and as you said before you
didn't even want to see it but that so
many of us have seen the end of
mainstream media we've watched our
academic and political institutions
crumble and then something like this
comes in and just takes the last
remaining foundation of it and then adds
fear to it and you take just fearful
people who don't even understand what
their rights are as you alluded to
earlier and then you really have have
the perfect storm to control everybody
now I I like this phrase the perfect
storm and I think it's the best
description to explain what's happened
to us really it wasn't it wasn't really
a conspiracy and from the top but of
course you know there's conspiracy
theories like will never stop them you
know they've been generated by the day
and if I had totally forgive that people
wanted one understand what happened to
their freedoms what's happened to their
rights what why did the world go dark
suddenly then people assume there's some
central plan I don't believe that
actually I think it's just this
gradation of factors and I I've been
wanting to kind of write about this Wow
but yeah it is a perfect storm it was a
howling media panic politicians and just
this onslaught you know come combined
with a lack of information but I've
described an epidemic crisis that led to
a complete panic but we're gonna be
we're gonna be spending the next ten
years trying to figure this out you know
like exactly how did this happen I let
me just draw attention to one thing Dave
and I'm not sure you're really with me
on this New York New York Times but I'm
a card
I probably you're not you left it long
ago but I have been listening together
daily for a long time and I and I'm an
admirer I'm a friends with Michael
barbero and and I like I think these
reporters are fantastic and I want this
to be a good paper but of course I want
it to be too
yeah well let me just be very clear on
that I want it to be every time even in
the last few days where I've had to go
after New York Times people just in the
last few days they did a piece on
misinformation in the age of corona and
they included my name and a chart about
a tweet that went viral and then I I
tweeted about it I tweeted about it and
I and I didn't even the author I had
never even heard of him before but then
he tweets back at me and says that I
wasn't even mentioned in the article
even though my name was in the chart in
the middle of the article he said that
doesn't count as a mention and it's like
you guys with all your doublespeak and
nonsense my name is in the chart in the
article like it I want them to be good I
I don't like it when people come up to
me on the street and say Dave you're one
of the few people I trust I go oh man
we're in a lot of trouble you know what
I mean gee they just have to be a little
less horrible but they seemingly can't
do it so I'm with you on that although
maybe I never thought they were as
wonderful as you did it's been
heartbreaking for me because I think and
I have to look back to the days here
because everything's a fog you know it's
a fog of Corona as they say but I think
it might have been early March when the
New York Times daily podcast which is
listened to by millions and millions of
people I mean it's beautiful podcast
beautifully produced fantastic venue
they they have on this this reporter a
diseased reporter and he comes on the
air and and begins to raise public panic
now there was no panic in those days but
and you'd think the New York Times would
be like a responsive venue usually
they're trying to diminish the panic you
know they're trying to like calm
everybody down that's usually the ethos
this was the opposite he was going we're
all gonna die oh my god you better carry
a Purell with you everywhere and spray
every single surface with hydrogen
peroxide and if we want to get rid of
this we're all going to have to drop in
place wherever you happen to be and and
live there for two months or else or
else who's gonna wipe out the whole
humanity this is a guy who was saying
this stuff and he has this authoritative
voice and he's very compelling
everything I listen to about the third
Kaster this guy now you get three times
to take over a what's a amounts to a
25-minute show three times in two weeks
you better be good
well I looked up the guy's background is
in epidemiologist was he trained in
medicine no does he know anything about
viruses no he Dave this gentleman has a
degree in rhetoric from Berkeley and I
was gonna guess creative writing
rhetoric is even better yeah so then
he's 66 years old so I'm thinking about
this what is his expertise she's got a
great voice for radio and he's some sort
of totalitarian I I don't know what it's
the same but they gave this guy this
basically what amounts to an hour and a
half over the course of two weeks to
spout off totalitarian blather and and
and and BS to their own how much of that
how much of that how much of that do you
think is just that the the New York
Times in this case because that's who we
happen to be talking about but we can
talk about it within a broader media
lens is that they've invested so much
time in a Russia collusion hoax they've
invested so much time in impeachment and
all of these things that did not work
that in many ways as Bill Maher said
about a year ago he would be all for the
economy tanking if that's what it takes
to take out Trump that they now see a
little blood in the water here and they
go oh if we have to destroy the entire
country to make sure this guy doesn't
win in November we'll kind of do it
because we got nothing left I mean this
is this is the one that they you know
it's one we couldn't have thought of and
it's the one that they have left
well I'm stunned that you you brought up
this idea and I have to admit that it it
hasn't been entirely out of my mind you
know I mean like I have actually
considered this too it's such a perverse
thought I think we need Sigmund Freud
himself to to take care of this one but
the timing is very interesting I mean we
had the Russia thing then we had the
Ukraine impeachment thing we have the
daily a fanaticism apparently the
tireless fanaticism I don't know what to
call it you know that every single day
run 18 articles accusing Trump of
ghastly pathology and anybody who
supports him as being just vermin who
needs to be exterminated and that's been
the ethos for the New York Times a very
very few exceptions there are a few
exceptions but but that's been the ethos
so I wonder sometimes too if that
explains maybe that doesn't explain
everything that's happened to us but it
explains the strange lust yeah a lot
early days yeah this this this burning
passion do like irrational desire to to
bring the economy down to accuse Trump
of something to to you know like in
Batman it's like some people just want
to see the world burn you know that line
I love that line Joker that's Heath
Ledger's Joker yeah yeah yeah so I look
I've thought of this too and it's it's a
extremely disturbing thought because
well let's just say when they you know
if they imagine that this is just gonna
be a political thing to take down Trump
what they've done is they dismantled
civilization however temporarily itself
and I don't think anybody could have
imagined this and and I've not talked to
Michael about this since then I hope I
would love to meet up with him because I
think he's a dear man and very charming
but I wonder if even he is turtled about
what his unleashed and by the way I'm
not sure that Michael himself is
responsible for his guesser you know I
mean like you pick your guess but maybe
you have full control with the program
Michael is just the host of the programs
I'm not sure Michael bears any moral
culpability for what happened to the New
York Times but alright so I don't know I
don't listen to them I don't listen to
the podcast but it's sort of like if you
think about it it's a New York Times
podcast we hate Trump we've tried to get
Trump every other way why not bring on
someone that as you said is not
medical expert or anything else but a
rhetorical a language expert
let's make everyone crazy because that
fits everything else we're doing but I
wanted to jump to something that you
said before because I think this is
really interesting you said I don't like
dealing in counterfactuals and I think
one part of this is how hindsight is
20/20 and everyone pretends to be an
expert today when they were ignoring
things way back when so I checked and
there was no mention of coronavirus at
any of the Democratic debates until the
last one that they had which was only
Bernie and Biden alone on March 25th and
that's when coronavirus was brought up
and there was no audience and everything
else they had debates on February 7th
February 19th and February 25th now
we've got the media running around and
all the Democratic politicians Pelosi
and Schumer and everybody running around
saying Trump should have done something
in January we all knew it bla bla bla it
not only didn't come up in any of their
debates but he did try for a China
travel ban in January what do you make
of that very that part of this that we
just sort of look at the people in
charge and we pick sort of randomly who
and when they should have done this or
that knowing that nobody else did
anything either nobody I mean it didn't
come up once why didn't it come up in
the debate on February 19th the one
right before the February 25th one if
everyone was talking about it you'd
think six dates before nothing strange
huh yeah look that is a great scoop
actually David I'd never even thought of
that before I mean I wrote my first
article on this topic January 27th you
know I mean like I could have written
about anything else but I was watching
what was going on in China I knew the
quarantines might be coming so I decided
to lean in and I discussed this in great
detail actually in January 27th II I did
this wouldn't even be brought up two
weeks later two-and-a-half weeks later
three weeks later and democratic debate
is actually that's extremely telling and
it looks like the Prophet says all ooh
you're an idiot you didn't prepare
properly for this oh yeah so they have
this hindsight thing and which is fine I
mean like we're not omniscient figures
you know right we don't
you know this were all a breast do talk
about this beautiful article again in
the New York Times today so they ran
good stuff beautiful article about about
how a few people they are are experts
about this at all but you would think
that early on that they would have
consulted me most about this and then it
just drives me crazy actually that once
they realize that coronavirus was a
thing
why didn't why do i why weren't they
calling epidemiologists and experts and
medical professionals and people with
specializations and dealing pandemic
diseases asking what they think you know
why didn't they why would they calling
John Owen itis or or Newt vidcon ski you
know from Rockefeller University or why
didn't they pay any attention to the 800
medical professionals epidemiologists
and biostatisticians that signed a
letter put out by Yale University
begging our nation's leaders and
political people to not shut down the
economy to not pursue this locked-in
strategy what why weren't it why wasn't
the press even slightly interested in
the fact that 800 medical professionals
associated with the OU university wrote
a public letter begging America's
political leaders to not do exactly what
they did
where has been the press throughout this
why has it been you Reason magazine
American Institute for Economic Research
and just a handful of other venues that
have been left to report what medical
professionals are saying I mean can you
imagine I mean I think about a guy like
like like Newt witkowski okay so it's
like 35 years of researching viruses
their transmission the policy response
to them how they work what you should do
and this is a serious guys the head you
know one of the heads of the human
genome project who this is his life and
he lives in New York and this whole
world unfolds before his eyes and the
whole world's collapsing right
his phone didn't ring he didn't get a
single email nobody asked him and and
finally you know just desperate and
shocked and horrified you know how do
you spend your life as a professional in
this area and then when the critical
moment in your life comes along where
where the civilization could use your
expertise everyone completely ignores
you and you're just some dude sitting
alone and you have to wait for an
independent filmmaker to come on do an
interview with you same thing happens
John and itis who had you know an
article in 2005 about fake science I
went that that took over the world he
was like be a star you know he's exposed
fake science his whole life he's a
specialist in biostatistics
and he had a lot to say about this stuff
nobody asked him you know I mean we we
destroyed the world without ever
consulting actual medical professionals
about this not the New York Times nobody
cared about the actual specialists in
this fields who were pleading and
begging and trying to find somebody to
talk to and get their message out to the
point that Yale University actually had
to distribute this open letter from 800
medical professionals which was
subsequently completely ignored by the
mainstream press it's a disgrace we're
gonna be dealing with this for years and
and I I think that there's gonna be hell
to pay
on the part of the mainstream press for
the what they've done what they've done
to the world the missed opportunities
the morally egregious abuse of their
power over the public mind in the in the
last month it just it's it sickens me
more than anything I've seen in my life
and and I like a free press I I believe
in press freedom I believe in all these
things I think it can and does work but
this is this is an abuse to cheer on the
the end of our rights and liberties like
this and so cavalierly and if you're
right as you are just asking the
questions and I'm asking the questions
to who is this all driven by a
pathological hatred of Trump is this is
this it is that what drove at all I
don't know but if that's true somebody
needs to be held accountable you know
it's so interesting listening to you
because there's
sort of undercurrent of your a non
alarmist when it comes to kovat itself
and you're trying to figure out how we
can be free and actually in the last
five minutes what really animates your
sort of fear factor your fear senses is
everything else related to it and I I
think that is where a lot of people are
at were we're at least confused as to
the real depth of the fear we should
have related to the virus itself and
where most people are trying their best
to do the best they can and not go
outside and the rest of it but that's
not really where the fear is I actually
think that the fear is what you're
talking about right now that it seems
like every sense making machine that
we've had is no longer functioning or is
trying to manipulate us we're seeing
through it in a very clear way and that
is freaking scary and especially for
people who maybe not my audience that's
sort of seen this for a while or the
younger internet audience but if you're
if you're a Boomer not to pile on the
Boomers all the time but if you're the
type of person that really isn't that
checked into this stuff but now you're
really starting to see it and you're
seeing that the future of your life your
retirement savings you know all of these
things are gonna change drastically the
world that you thought existed doesn't
exist anymore that's I think much
scarier than then actually getting sick
at the moment that's a real question we
wouldn't hear on mainstream media no but
you are exactly right and I I knew that
this was true from I would say probably
the first week of March that the most
terrifying thing was not was not the
virus you know we deal with annual new
flu flu strains every year and we have
for 150,000 years actually we have
medical professionals to do with this we
have we have therapies we have ways to
deal with it I mean we we have tests we
have vaccines we have herd immunity
strategies we know what we're doing and
dealing with disease when it comes to
dealing with a
a totalitarian state apparatus that's
taking away your rights and liberties as
cheered on by a howling deeply ignorant
media apparatus that's what's really
scary I was writing this morning Dave if
I can just quickly tell you about this
and I'm sure we all have way stories but
but I have an accountant here at the
American Institute for Economic Research
who's whose founding money for my
receipts from March and I'm busy I
couldn't get to it until this morning
I'm busy but then you know what it's
like to go through your receipts you've
been through there you've been there
before so now the receipts day from
March 1st so I I got to see every Amtrak
it took every restaurant I ate at the
hotels I stayed at the taxi cab that
took various things the glassware I
bought for the house and so on so I had
to relive this month you know through my
receipts and it was it was horrifying I
mean like I really had a sense that this
is the old world this is the new world
but one day I seized on was March 12
because I was in the city going to a
television interview and I was there
with my friend to lead Brown and the
city was starting to panic it was very
interesting then and we got there about
10:30 and my interview wasn't really to
4:00 so I had about four hours to kill
so I went to my favorite Irish pub and
we sat down and they were instead of
open tables they were suddenly paper on
the table classes and when people knew
that something was coming but they
didn't know what it was they knew for
sure by this point that there was a
virus and probably it was in New York
but that's not what was really in the
air what was in the air was the fear of
the response you know like like we can
deal with viruses
you know don't sneeze on him you don't
cough on me maybe set my down over there
I'll pick it up you know we can deal
with it okay
I caught the virus gosh I beat down a
couple of days and so on we can deal
with that but the idea of something the
Amtrak close.i
didn't know what was gonna happen to
this street shut down the cops arresting
people in bars I mean we didn't know
what was gonna happen and to lead and I
sat there between 10:30 and 11:00 I tell
you Dave what was very interesting that
I have to write about this but the bars
were packed they were packed and not
because people thought life is normal
but they just were certain that life was
about to become really unnormal and they
were drooling or just gathered around
and drinking themselves silly I said to
the person who was waiting on us I said
have you ever seen this kind of drinking
at 11:00 a.m. she goes I've been here
five years I've never seen anything like
this she was drinking themselves silly
out of fear hot of the virus so much but
uh yeah of the other day of the public
panic and the political response and and
those hours that went by between 11:00
and 4:00 when I finally did my interview
were terrifying because I just didn't
know if we could even get the next train
out and after the interviewer we rushed
to Penn Station just as fast as we could
and when we got on that Amtrak we were
both just breathing a sigh of relief and
and and even then I wasn't sure if the
train was gonna move so when it started
moving and I looked at be mess I do you
know I know it's a two-hour trip but
when that train stops at Hudson that's
when my heart is gonna stop racing
because this is terrifying yeah and
there's so many there's so many versions
of this one of the things that I've been
thinking about personally is my my
grandmother in law is 85 lives alone in
New Jersey none of her children or
grandchildren live in Jersey so we've
been having food delivered to her and I
have a friend that lives about 30 miles
away who's dropped off some stuff but
the idea that what if the states close
their borders
you know what if you can't get food to
somebody all of these things that we
thought these things would never be
possible in an American contest the fact
that the fact that all of us right now
are eating home all the time and just
hoping that Amazon can keep delivering
things I actually you know it's it's the
weird thing because the silver lining is
I think maybe we did need a shock to our
system to understand really what is
freedom and what is
what is being independent and not so
reliant on the system so I am I am
enthused about that but I'm also worried
that a lot of people haven't ever
thought about it before and then now
they're gonna suddenly think about it
and then and then who knows which way
they'll go because they might just put
their hands up and say no just help me
government please do everything for me
I'm just completely incapable of doing
anything I wonder I wonder what the
response is going to be and I think
that's that's partly your job and partly
at my job and in the days and weeks and
months coming if ideas matter all
getting out the message of freedom and
liberty and prosperity and and safety
through those things is I can't imagine
more important work than that right now
I mean it it's going to require voices
like yours to teach out there to help
people understand and make sense of
what's happened because philosophy
doesn't just come automatically people
need to be able to hear a body of ideas
and connect it with their own experience
and if we do this right we can make a
difference I believe because because the
reality is all around us but it needs
interpretation first it needs a body of
thought to connect it and and and we're
all struggling with that messaging I
mean my messaging is like why didn't
they leave it to the medical industry
and to society itself to handle instead
of having the politicians take over
because that is the politicians and the
regulators that have had ruined the
world I mean they've took a bad thing
which is a virus but actually not the
first virus and not the last one and
turn it into a calamity for civilization
that's not that's not a good thing and I
hope that coming out of this we're gonna
put massive restrictions on on on the
political class I mean I don't mean just
a constitutional you look at because
it's framed on your wall I mean
something that's really binding that
makes something like this impossible so
the court system actually works so if a
mayor tries to lock you in your home
again the courts will say no and then
and then suddenly he's out of power
that's the kind of system we need we
need massive deregulation
in the medical world and in the labor
markets in every area you mean you don't
think it's a great idea that my you
don't think it's a great idea that my
mayor here Eric Garcetti here in Los
Angeles is asking us to snitch on our
neighbors if they're doing something
they're not supposed to do and we might
get a reward for it
you think that's a problem I mean my dog
Clyde and I we've been out taking walks
and we're hunting down people because
we're trying to get some of that reward
money is that a problem you know I hope
that people will reflect on I'm basic
humane values going forward you know
like decency towards each other and and
freedom and that that that in a moral
sense that we all have will prevail over
our desire to destroy Geoffrey I think
that's the right way to end an interview
you truly are one of like the clear sane
voices and I think it's really it's
really shining right now so I'm thrilled
that I can help amplify you gotta at a
time like this and just stay safe and
saying and I look forward to actually
doing this in studio hopefully in the
not too distant future and then we'll go
to a bar at 11:00 a.m. and get wasted
and commiserate over you know the rights
that we lost how does that sound
it sounds great David it's wonderful to
count you as a friend we all need each
other right now
both friendship but also philosophical
allies let's let's let's go forward here
with with moral conviction and
intellectual integrity and ignore those
around us and just do what we know is
right I think that's the best hope we
have and that is how you end an
interview if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out in our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell